like a lot of people out there over the
last month or so i've been playing
around quite a bit with this ai art
generator called wombo and it generates
some quite beautiful in some cases
images in other cases quite grotesque
and i think i'm going to do a couple
videos about this the first one is going
to be centered on the prompt in which i
used my full name including my
confirmation name
gregory brian ignatius sadler and i just
wanted to see what it would generate and
so i'm going to show you some of them
and we'll run through them and look at
some of the features and you can try
this out yourself i'll put the
link to it in the video description so
you can easily try it out for yourself
there are a number of different styles
that you can select for the prompt that
you enter and each of them generates a
different kind of
look to it some of them are more
successful than others and so
the first one that we're actually going
to
take a look at is an example of what
they call the ukiyoe style i don't know
if i'm pronouncing that right but good
enough
and you can see that this one generated
something that clearly has a face
and
doesn't look like me well not really but
i'm not sure what it's actually
working from and as we pan our way
down the
drawing we see a lot of cool features to
it you know it's almost like wallpaper
behind it that looks vaguely
like writing but isn't actually writing
and then there's a face and you notice
that the eye is clearly distinctive is
that a mouth is that an ear who knows
and we go all the way down to the bottom
there's a kind of weird collar going on
there so that's that one
the next one was pastel and i did this
with the same prompt uh but i didn't
have the ignatius in there so it might
have turned out as something different
and this is kind of a cool
wizard of sorts it looks like it's
starting out at the very top of it you
know there's these waves of blue and
pinks and greens woven together and we
pan our way down and you see the wizard
sitting there that looks like a face
looks like legs and arms and then
finally we get to the bottom and it's
almost as if this is all folded up
clothing or something like that
then synthwave was kind of interesting
as well again there's a face it's a
futuristic kind of
you know tech
oriented very neon
look to it we can pan our way down this
one and you can see
that you know it's like a robot face
maybe with an open mouth and then
there's the shoulders
and it blends into something that looks
like almost like a train so there's you
know robot greg doing his thing and
here's another figurative one this is
coming from the steampunk
generator
choice i like this one quite a bit it's
pretty cool i'm gonna go the other way
with this so you notice that there's all
this stuff on the bottom
that is uh architectural and we work our
way up to
something that again looks like a face
but look at that eye with the missing
eye eyeball and then it's got a head
that is essentially
uh a helmet that's that's
architectural as well it's wearing some
sort of building
the next one i don't remember exactly
which one this this came from but it's a
cool one another face involved here
another set of architectural features
and some landscape stuff fading off in
the background so if we start at the
bottom
we see again some
maybe houses or buildings of some sort
and they blend their way up into the
shoulder
of the person who is sitting there
clearly an old man
in front of mountains that blend up into
the sky so very cool this one is a bit
more grotesque right we've got a guy who
appears to be holding his head and has a
hand that looks sort of like
birds maybe or feathers or fingers or
something like that sitting there and so
if we start at the top there's some cool
stylized background there's the the head
um shoulders are are you know
headless
and actually the fingers almost look
like
a couple different hands put together
there's something that seems to be in
his lap that could be another face
perhaps and then we get all the way down
to the bottom
this is another one that turned out
really really cool
and i think this is dark fantasy this
this particular one a guy sitting there
maybe he's uh doing some magic or
something like that you notice all these
things again in the air that look like
they could be characters or writing and
then it comes down to
him with oh it almost looks like there's
an aura around him or a halo
there's that weird orangey thing off to
the side that may be attached to him
and it goes all the way down to the
bottom where we've we've got something
like a vaguely human lamp maybe sitting
in a chair
here's another cool one from vibrant
and i like this this is also figurative
as well the colors are
you know it answers quite well to the
word vibrant we've got some sort of
maybe reptilian sort of figure again a
lot of sitting figures that get
generated from my name and some
beautiful imagery there
then we had something that was kind of
weird the hd one
when i entered my name just gave you
this
i'm not gonna pan through it because
what is this it looks like maybe
you know bits of a leather couch or
something with light shining on it or
maybe it's something skin or i don't
know maybe it's just light effects we go
on to the next one and this one is
semi-figurative but it's harder to pick
out what exactly is happening
here this kind of looks like i mean i
want to say it looks like a combination
between a
snail a slug and a rhinoceros maybe or
some other kind of
herbivore with there's also a face there
and we see other faces showing up as we
go down so this one's pretty trippy and
it's hard to figure out what precisely
it's supposed to be
and then this last one is really quite
cool i i
very much enjoy looking at this one
this might be from the
mystical one
and we've got a figure at the very top
on
standing on top of what might be a city
and then we scroll down
there's these three or four actually
five little luminescent spots of yellow
and we get all the way down to the
bottom and it looks almost like a hat
with perhaps some figures on it it's not
quite clear what it is and then it
blends into
a
sort of uh
basis or background for it so these are
the
ones that i found using my name you can
enter stuff in yourself and see what it
produces for you you might get a kick
out of it you might get weirded out but
it's uh well worth trying it's free and
and
appears to generate some pretty cool
images so that's it for this one but i
will do some other ones in the near
future as well
you